Russia has launched a wave of airstrikes
across Ukraine Kiev says it's
intercepted more than half of them
earlier on Saturday a two-year-old girl
was killed in a missile attack on the
city of danipro five more children were
amongst 22 injured in the strike on a
residential area an emergency services
building was also hit
speaks Charles Stratford he joins us
live now from Kiev first of all Charles
tell us more about these attacks that
we're seeing across Ukraine
yes firstly Laura that attack we
understand on a residential area that
certainly hit a residential suburb just
outside the city of danipro that's in
central Ukraine the governor of that
region saying that a two-year-old girl's
body was pulled from the rubble
yesterday evening and as you say at
least 22 other people injured in that
attack including five children this is
part of what we've seen in in recent
days and weeks of increasing attacks by
Russia targeting various sites across
the country the authorities here in Kiev
saying that all the Russian cruise
missiles and so-called Kamikaze drones
that targeted areas in the capital were
intercepted but I think it's an
indication of Russia stepping the up
these attacks as the build up towards
this expected Ukrainian
counter-offensive continues something
that the Ukrainian authorities we
understand have been preparing for four
months and likewise the Russians
preparing their defensive positions
what preparations have we seen Charles
in any indication as to when this much
anticipated counter-offensive will begin
or perhaps the most sort of categorical
language we heard a couple of days ago
from President Vladimir zielinski he's
saying the first time that his forces
are in his words ready for this
counter-offensive we understand
according to
um Western military intelligence and
Military analysts that this
counter-offensive could involve up to 12
trained brigades these are soldiers that
have been trained by Ukrainian allies
that could amount to around 10 000
soldiers we also know that there is
going to be hundreds of Tanks artillery
pieces and air defense systems that are
also going to be involved exactly how
this plays out though remains to be seen
exactly where and when we understand
according to military analysts that we
could expect to see pushes or what they
describe as faints in certain areas
along the uh around about a thousand
kilometer Frontline as Ukrainian forces
probe in and look for week points in
Russia's defenses but we've also seen
satellite imagery of heavily defended
areas the Russians have had a long time
to prepare
for this character offensive we've seen
satellite imagery of
kilometers of tank traps and trenches
which we understand are heavily defended
especially in and around that area north
of Crimea and interestingly in recent
days we've seen increasing attacks by
the ukrainians we understand targeting
supply lines in sudden zaparasia
specifically that port city of berdyansk
which is deep inside Russian occupied
territory and the Russian installed
authorities in Northern Crimea said
yesterday that they intercepted another
five Ukrainian drones that we understand
were targeting supply lines in Northern
Crimea I think it's really important to
emphasize though as this
counter-offensive is expected to start
there is a lot of pressure on the
ukrainians on the Ukrainian government
here from their Western allies those
allies having supplied Ukraine with
obviously tens of billions of dollars
worth of military equipment and training
for thousands of troops they want some
sort of result from this
counter-offensive account offensive that
many say could well determine the
outcome of this war Charles Stratford
brings the latest there from Keith
thanks very much